today i'm going to be speaking with
coleman hughes who's a fellow
at the manhattan institute and
contributing editor
at city journal also host of the podcast
conversations with coleman uh thanks for
doing this i i've been hoping we were
going to be able to do this at some
point and i guess the time is now
glad to be here thanks for having me so
i guess to start with
for the portion of my audience that's
not familiar with you or your work
in preparation for this interview i was
seeing you know things written about you
things
you've done your podcast etc and
frequently you're referred to as a
black conservative intellectual is that
term
conservative being ascribed to you
do you consider yourself conservative
does the traditional left-right spectrum
even really mean anything to you at this
point or is that are you
sort of operating outside of it maybe
i'm curious
whether that sort of um word resonates
with your views
uh no i've never thought of myself as a
conservative i
grew up during the bush era
laughing at the you know the craziness
of the religious right
instinctively and instinctively
identifying as a liberal
and uh i find many of the things i
say are things obama would have said in
2007 or 2008
um and
so no i don't uh there's lots of
conservatives that i've read and admired
there's lots of liberals i've read and
admired but i don't think of
uh you know what i say and my ideas as
being either liberal or conservative
i don't really think too much in those
terms when you look right now
and this will probably serve to get us
into some of the things i've
you know you've been commenting on
lately
when you look now at the political lines
that sort of exist in the united states
either around uh the police protests
that we're seeing
these issues of uh troops in portland
and other cities and
uh you know different folks either
focusing on
the legality and constitutionality of
protests versus
troops and others focusing more on the
reasons for the protest
does anything in particular resonate
with you
from any of what is in the sort of
political discourse and
or does anything particularly repel you
or seem to you as
misguided or incorrect
um you're speaking about the discourse
coming from protests
yeah coming from catalyzed by protests
but not necessarily strictly from the
protest stores but from the entire
discussion of this issue in society so
what resonates
with me about the discourse that
is catalyzed by protest is the
frustration with the fact that police
aren't held accountable when
they mess up or do wrong it's not to say
they are never
held accountable but they are generally
not held accountable
you just look up any news story of a
police officer
shooting uh you know someone regardless
of their race
regardless of the race of the officer or
the person shot
the odds that they were even disciplined
much less
uh prosecuted is close to zero
um and the only the only times that's
not true
is when a cop does something like shoot
someone in the back while they're lying
face down
something truly where there's truly no
possible justification
so i resonate with that kind of
frustration with
wanting to get to a place where
those kinds of things happen never or
extremely rarely
um i don't resonate with the
uh you know the general
the general attitude towards the cops as
bad people or as racists
i don't think i think that is untrue
um i think you know
broadly the i've been to several black
lives matter protests for example
and the the typical chants are like
nypd suck my dick and that's something i
i have no
really i have no
sympathy with i don't i think it's um i
think it's ridiculous
needlessly antagonistic and serves
nobody
i also don't resonate with uh you know
the defund
idea i think that's sort of misplaced i
very much resonate with reform smart
reform
so that's a picture of kind of what i
resonate with and what i don't
one thing you mentioned which i think
might be interesting to hear because
there's so many debates about who is
racist and whether something is an
example of a racist individual
or a or a racist symptom or
a a sort of racialized vestige of
something from the past
how what's a good way to determine
whether an individual
is racist and do you is it possible
because sometimes i'll read a position
that says
really what you're talking about is mind
reading if you're trying to figure out
what even if
even what someone says wouldn't
necessarily tell you
what is deep in their mind and so we
have to focus merely on
the social repercussions of a policy and
getting away from
talking about whether an individual is
racist question one is
does racism at the individual level
matter in terms of the way you're
looking at these issues and number two
how what's a good way to think about
whether an individual is racist
um i think so
the word racism is a moving target it's
not unique
there's a lot of words like that or what
it means 60 years ago isn't what it
means today
and you can you can fight that but at
the end of the day
that that's how language works we're
always sort of updating these terms
so i think but that does present a
problem because
if you want to have a deep a deep
and a an opinion on what it means to be
racist
that survives even a 10-year time period
you have to find some other way of
thinking about it other than just
accepting
you know the zeitgeist and i think the
important the way to do that is to
to ask of any particular person what
kind of world do they want to live in
if they had the power what would they
make american society look like
would they want it to look like the jim
crow south
or even less extreme would they want it
to look like
slum living conditions for black people
and
you know kind of less than
you know a kind of less
formalized but equally severe
segregation
or would they want us to live in an
integrated and wealthy society where
people have lots of
opportunity that's the important
question so if you if you fall on the
right side of that question
i have trouble calling you any kind of
racist
or i have trouble thinking of you as a
racist in
in any sense of that word that should
really matter to me
ethically even if you like
laugh at a racist joke or like you know
have some kind of subconscious bias
because i think frankly almost everyone
does if you could if you could have
a perfectly transparent look into every
person's mind
as bill burr once said you know if we
did that on friday we'd all be fired by
monday if
if we're being honest i think so the
kind of racism i'm
that is worth worrying about is is the
kind of racism
that gets the wrong answer to the
question of what kind of world you want
to live in
are there specific systems in the united
states right now
that meet that criteria for you that you
think have to be changed and i guess the
context of that question is you said
in your expression of the frustrations
you have with policing
you said you it is not at the top of
your list that
a large swath of individual officers are
racist so maybe to go further is is
there some system that you believe in
practice
is even if not by definition racist
is having a a racialized effect today
which you believe needs to be changed
so i guess my top candidate for that
would be the war on drugs
um in in practice
what it has meant for various reasons um
not all of which have to do with racism
but in effect you know the effect is
sort of the same
what is meant is that a lot of young
black boys
you know spend a day in jail come into
contact with the system
over having an amount of drugs that
is truly negligible and that
if it were a wine mom smoking weed in la
no one would no one would care
there's been a you know at any given
time very few people in prison
are there only because of weed but
because the sentences are so quick and
people just spend a night in jail there
is a revolving door effect where just
over over time huge amounts of of people
go in and out over things that shouldn't
be crimes to begin with and
that embitters them to the police it
embitters them to the system
and it's horrible for the relationship
between the cops
and civilians i think a lot of cops
don't even want to enforce those laws
it's a drag for them
so that and it's fallen
disproportionately
on black and hispanic men in particular
so we can go into the reasons for that
but
the reasons are less important than
realizing that it it's not
serving our society and
understanding that we should end it as
much as
as quickly as we can if you think about
reforming that specifically i've not
heard you talk about this in particular
but it's something i've been reading
about and i'm wondering what your
thoughts are
there's a lot of discussion about
traffic enforcement as a catalyst
that opens the door to a lot of those
war on drugs type interactions
where there's a significant amount of
discretion like you're talking about a
wine mom
versus a young black or hispanic kid as
an example
so there's a lot of discussion around
traffic enforcement
where you could be if the if the officer
decides you could be let off with a
verbal warning and no inquiry about
searching a vehicle or if the officer
decides maybe they say this is the
vehicle i want to search or a tail light
out or this type of thing
do you think traffic enforcement may be
a focus
where we can eliminate an area of
significant discretion among officers
that could lead to these disparities
so i'm curious what that would look like
in practice
but by eliminating officer discretion do
you mean having someone else do the job
or do you mean
having them follow a kind of stricter
rubric so the two
most popular things i'm reading about
are either or a combination of
replacing a lot of traffic enforcement
not dui
but a lot of traffic enforcement stuff
with cameras uh
stop light infractions speeding
infractions of certain kinds etc
or having some different
part of or non-police individuals
handle certain types of traffic
enforcement either or both of those
ideas
so i like the first idea um i mean
selfishly
as a driver who you know occasionally
wants to speed like like everyone else i
think
the idea of having a more certain
enforcement of it through cameras is
obviously unappealing
but from the point of view of society as
a whole like obviously a
camera is going to do a better job it's
completely unbiased
it's also more a more certain kind of
punishment
certain i mean like in in that you're
going to get punished 100 of the time if
you if you if it catches your license
plate
which means that whatever laws it's
enforcing are going to be better
enforced
to interject one thing there coleman the
way in which the cameras could be biased
is based on where they are placed and
obviously you can imagine ways that you
choose the selection of where the
cameras go
that could still have a very biased
effect
right and i imagine that would be in the
hands of state and local authorities
which might vary wildly in their
competence yes
um so yeah there is definitely
yeah anywhere that humans are in the
chain human error and human bias
is possible it's i guess it's a relative
question of
whether that would be better or worse
than the status quo it'd be interesting
to test it out in a particular location
as for substituting someone besides the
cops
for you know pulling people over
i don't know i i think
i i i'm curious why that would be better
or why those people wouldn't encounter
wouldn't be subject to the same errors
and um and um
beyond errors like injustices that cops
would perpetrate
and why they wouldn't be subject to the
same
uh um
the same sort of challenges that cops
face
you know you you look look up a video of
youtube
of a cop trying to pull someone over
pulls down the window shoots and leaves
instantly
whoever whoever the car whoever we get
to do the cops job
is going to be stuck in the following
situation one they
want to do their job if they're a good
person they want to do their job
without needlessly
harming the person that they're pulling
over
two they understand that even if one in
every
thousand people they pull over is
psychotic
that means if they do their job long
enough they could get a bullet in their
skull
and they have to treat every interaction
so as to guard against the pos the one
in a thousand possibility
a cop gets shot something like 300 cops
get shot every year
in america which again not a huge number
but
you know just you know 50 unarmed
americans getting killed
every year changes the way that
civilians
feel when they see a cop certainly 300
cops
getting shot every year changes the way
a cop feels when he's pulling over a
suspect even if he knows he's not likely
to be one of those 300
so whoever we get to do the job is going
to encounter
what i'm saying is the job it's not an
accident that the job
is leads to these kind of things yes
there are the horrible bad apples like
like derek chovin
but more broadly the job is inherently
difficult
because of the nature of the job i want
to talk about that
in a moment but because you broach this
idea of police officer walks up to a car
window rolls down someone with a gun is
there
i've heard you multiple times say that
really
the ways in which police can be reformed
and that these conversations have to
happen
can't ignore the context of the number
of firearms owned by civilians in the
united states i've heard you say this a
number of times in different interviews
and i don't always hear this
even from folks who are to some degree
skeptical of the way in which
some of these reform and defund
movements are being carried forward
that's a unique circumstance that is
very different than some of the european
countries where the default is
the police don't walk around with a
firearm but it's in the vehicle if they
need it
and that i mean how do you even start
parsing that because there's really no
way to discuss that
without talking about gun laws in the
united states
yeah yeah it's a it's an extremely
tricky issue and
it's it's an american issue it's a very
peculiarly american issue
because you know when mass shootings
happen we all sort of recognize
that at minimum
the reason we see this so much here and
not in other places because
is is at least partly to do with that we
have a very
strange gun culture and i don't mean
strange in a judgmental way i just mean
strange from the point of view of
very few other places in the world that
we compare to
compare ourselves to in fact really
nowhere else in the world is quite like
us
yeah and that has consequences it's it's
easy to get a gun if you're a crazy
person
if you live in most you know many states
and that's not true elsewhere in the
world
um and then so so there there's a legal
ease of getting a legal gun problem but
then there's also
you know just the fact that there's so
many illegal guns in america
uh and it's it's unclear even how legal
gun reform you know um
uh laws would curb that kind of problem
i have to imagine a lot of the people
shooting cops are not doing it with
legally
obtained weaponry so there's like a
there's like a very tricky problem here
of how do you
there's like a black market problem how
do you get rid of things that are
extremely desired
and extremely valuable on a black market
that's been operating
you know and has probably very well
established
networks for like untold numbers of
years how do you interrupt that you know
we we haven't been able to do it with
drugs probably can't do it with guns
but it makes policing in america
completely different than say in the uk
when it comes to the the issue of the
officer's job being difficult and part
of the difficulty being from those guns
it still stands to reason to me that
longer training that includes
significantly more training
as a social worker on de-escalation that
would you know
if we're committed or if we decide that
at least for now
for a lot of these situations because
there are 350 million guns floating
around
or more officers need to be armed and it
needs to be officers doing these
things it seems there's a huge benefit
to be had
from officers who are spending
the time in training that officers in
some other countries do
with a lot of that focus being on how to
de-escalate situations rather than end
up escalating them
and that i think is something that is
opposed
for different reasons by different
players
uh sometimes it's a cost issue sometimes
it's
actually people who seem to not really
want what they would consider
sort of softer type policing they
believe that there's something either
moral or or
strategically beneficial in in not
training officers in that way but that
seems like something that
would immediately make an impact in my
from my view what do you think
yeah i think i've heard you know i've
seen
circulating on social media the
comparisons between
the average number of hours cops get
trained and you know
other professions that are totally not
life and death professions that actually
get much more training seems like a
no-brainer that we should want to
train cops and i don't i
i disagree that there's
you know i i think more training would
have to mean the cops
get trained to de-escalate situations
both for
the benefit of themselves and
and civilians because a great cop
is also likely more likely to keep him
or herself safe
has that has to be true yes so i don't
think there's any kind of
i think it's totally a positive some
win-win game
um for for cops and civilians when it
comes to the protests to go back a
little bit to
to what has gotten you thinking in more
detail recently about some of these
issues
sometimes i'll see an article that says
um you know
at this particular black lives matter
protest
most of the protesters were white as an
example
how should we seed it you see that is
there is there significance to that what
should we
glean from that what should we not glean
from it the makeup of protesters
themselves
um i i don't glean too much from it um
i've you know i've been to a lot of
protests uh
some of them were more diverse than
others so you know white people are 60
70 percent of the country
if they make up that much of a protest
it's it's not
the only thing the only thing that
should tell you is that the protests
are you know fairly widely subscribed
between different racial groups and
there's
there's lots i mean if the point they're
trying to make is that there's not that
many black
you know peop that that's just
cherry-picking um so i
i don't think you should use the
demographics of the protest to score a
political point either for or against
them
um and interestingly enough i've heard
it used by by people
across the political spectrum but for
different reasons
yeah i'm i have to imagine that if
you're if you're against the protest and
trying to paint them as
you know just all all white then that's
sort of gonna
that kind of thinking is gonna come back
to to bite you somehow and it's
i mean it's just not true of the
protests i've seen in
nyc i imagine it just varies between
protests and between locations and
there's not too much
to glean one of the things that seems to
be
widespread in terms of polling on issues
right now
in in terms of the president is that the
top three issues
continue to be right now uh coronavirus
the state of the economy which is of
course significantly linked to what's
going on with coronavirus
and number three this sort of kind of
catch-all that includes
race relations and response to protests
and response to the killing of george
floyd
um and donald trump is suffering pretty
significantly in terms of approval there
it's where you see one of the biggest
gaps when you ask people do you think by
how well do you think biden would do
versus how well
is donald trump doing today when you
look at the situation
do you think that those numbers make
sense based on what has empirically
taken place
do you think that there is a level of
either confusion
or propagandizing around that that is
influencing those numbers do
do they confuse you but you're not
necessarily sure why
you're talking about trump's approval
numbers on that third category yes
exactly
well so
tabling the issue of whether donald
trump is a racist which comes back to
what we
you know your first question yeah and
not at all my question here
right yeah no so so
is donald trump great at dealing with
racially sensitive issues i think
clearly the answer to that is no okay um
his whole style of
of and it's part of what makes him
appealing is that he
says the first thing that comes to his
mind he seems much more authentic he
seems like
he he's the type of politician that has
an opinion that he hasn't
he'll have an opinion that he hasn't uh
you know
tested a thousand times you know on on
and like you know market tested before
he's had it and that's what makes him
appealing
but it also means that you know when
when riots are happening and he says
you know when the when the looting shark
when the looting starts the shooting
starts
yeah you know that's that's not the tone
you want to strike at that moment
to sort of calm the country right and
he's
he's he's constitutionally incapable
of saying just the right thing at the
right time
he likes saying the thing that pisses
off the left which is to me
um a very bad quality in a president i
want a president
whether they're republican or democrat
that is not
looking to piss off the other side that
is
at least making some kind of effort to
say that i value the things that
you on that side value um
and trump is is bad at that
i i wonder how good biden would be i i
think he would be better
based on you know based on
his record and his personality but
um it depends how much pressure he feels
from the left wing of the democratic
party to
um you know
to pass every progressive purity test
um and so it remains to be seen
how much of the division of the country
is actually
a structural problem that will
exist regardless of who the president is
because the nation itself is divided
and how much is donald trump's
idiosyncratic personality and
like love for combat
one of the things that's really
interesting about you mentioning
this idea of as a priority just angering
the other side
that's interesting to me is before trump
i had a view of not necessarily the
american right but at least the the
makeup of the republican party is being
primarily made up of three kind of
categories
the sort of mitt romney low-tax
pro-business republicans
who may have some socially conservative
views or not right like this could
include maybe a guy like john kasich who
at least as far as i know is less
socially conservative that was sort of
one category
you then had the very religiously
motivated voters who tended to be more
evangelical christians but there were
you know could be mormons could be
conservative catholics as well you know
but bunch of different but more
religiously minded groups that are
focused on issues like abortion and gay
marriage
and then the kind of libertarian leaning
what maybe grew into the tea party
freedom and liberty type crowd and those
are the main three categories
one of the the fourth category that now
you've sort of alluded to are folks that
i don't really see caring very much
about policy
but they're kind of motivated by the
idea of having someone that
triggers the left for lack of a better
term so they're for the wall if trump
wants it
but if he doesn't get it or it gets
blown over by wind like happened over
the weekend or whatever
the wall was never really it was the
idea of the wall and part of it was
really the fact that the left
doesn't like the wall and that's a big
motivating factor
that seems particularly dangerous to me
because
it seems if that's your priority you
will go with anything that could
potentially
anger the other side and allow really
really bad things uncritically
i i agree with that i think i agree that
um
i would say it's not just
the faction on the right i do think a
lot of politics is about angering the
other side and like
like seeing the other side lose power
and be in emotional pain as a kind of
way of gleaning pleasure i think that
that's what a lot of politics is about
but i do agree with you there is there
is a distinct
um trump following that
in the past five or seven years
um wouldn't be associated with any other
element of the typical
right as we knew it until like 2015 or
so
um yeah i mean i think in general
it's a horrible idea to ground your
politics in
any kind of zero sumness like you know
your the other side's loss is not
necessarily your gain
we all have to live together in this
country we're you know we're stuck on a
boat together and we have to find a way
to live together
so it's absolutely unwise to
you know just team up with a faction and
want to see your team win
at all costs that's what sports is for
so let's not
make politics sports it already kind of
is that but let's
always fight that urge within ourselves
so in the somewhat
limited time we have left as you think
about
the next sort of phase of american
politics which may be four more years of
donald trump
it may not be it may be joe biden maybe
with a democratic senate maybe not we
really don't know yet
if we pull back a little bit from that
level of analysis of how elections in
three months are going to go
where would you like to see the
conversation go in terms of
the division that now exists aside from
assigning blame and saying well
part of it may be the growth of this
anger the other side mentality
part of it is failed leadership on some
issues as you've pointed out trump
typically not saying the right thing
when it comes at least to race relations
what's like the big conversation that
you see is the important one to have
over the next say 12 to 18 months once
we're past
this upcoming election i think we need
some kind of return to normalcy
and i know that that that's going to
piss off all the people who think that
trump
you know shook up the system and you
know
the deep state and yada yada yada but we
we do need we need a
a cultural and rhetorical return to
something you know
some some place where we can
avoid the craziness on the far left
of you know your race is the most
important thing about you
and if you're not my race then there are
things about me you'll never be able to
understand
because that's an that that just
precludes
everything that i thought
everything every impulse that i thought
i was
fighting racism from that goes against
um and then we have to get
we have to get someone in the white
house that
you know is just
more of a is more committed to uniting
the country
that is my fundamental problem with
trump i don't have so many problems with
his policies
um i don't think he is the the boogeyman
that he's been made out to be
on the left i don't think he's the white
supremacist
that many people think he is
but i think he's horrible at uniting the
country
i think you know i know i know people
off the top of my head you know friends
that i think could
strike a better note of of uniting the
country without
you know at all being even on the left
per se
so so yeah i think the conversation we
need to be having is
is something about you know remembering
what
values that people on the left and the
right sort of
kind of agree on and
emphasizing those remembering those
just one thing to mention it sounds like
you and i probably have
relatively similar views about what you
alluded to regarding identity politics
where we might differ and i'm curious is
i don't think that that
degree of sort of the toxic extreme
identity politics
really has any presence like for example
in the biden campaign
do you see that as something that would
be prevalent if joe biden were to win
because i think that that exists mostly
outside of the democratic party
mainstream
somewhere far to its left i think that's
exactly right i think
it would be hard to explain why biden
won in the first place if that were not
true
um people people wanted what biden was
offering which was
not what kamala harris or or
you know elizabeth warren or bernie
sanders people wanted biden
and even black people voted
overwhelmingly for biden yes
um so there is that but there
there is also the fact that
folks who are very into identity
politics have a lot of disproportionate
cultural power they are seen as being
larger in number than they are and they
occupy positions of
you know elite at elite cultural
institutions
that make them you know have more power
proportional to their mass and it's a
question of whether joe biden
to what extent he will resist the
the wing of his own party that is
you know constantly demanding that he be
more
like them i think he's been able to
resist it and that's
partly why he's been successful um but
it's a it's a genuine question i have
of whether and for how long he'll be
able to
resist it yeah my my instinct is having
observed the same thing as you which is
so far
it seems to have been i don't even know
that i would use resist but
it has not permeated his campaign to say
the least
i i would imagine that only if something
changed
would that be it be something that
happens and i don't
i have a hard time imagining what that
would be well george floyd could have
been
and then the riots that ensued could
have been something that changed
had biden been president at the time no
i mean
even just the the enormous cultural
upswing in you know people
imagining that the answer to what
happened to george floyd
is to focus more and more on the race of
individual people the race of
politicians
um this is what people it's just obvious
to many people that this is the answer
to what
we saw in minneapolis and i think that's
wrong but
to the extent that more and more people
believe that there will be more and more
pressure on the biding campaign
to show signal that they care about
the issue of police brutality by
proposing the specific remedies that are
on offer
further on the left understanding
whether or not those offers work they
will be seen
as the only way to care about the issues
so i do worry about that
i understand your point yeah that will
be that will be interesting to follow
we've been speaking with coleman hughes
who's a fellow at the manhattan
institute
contributing editor at city journal and
also host of the podcast
conversations with coleman which i've
been checking out
uh coleman i really appreciate your time
and and i'm glad we were finally able to
do this
absolutely it was fun